the Joe Rogan experience but I was doing
a show on Sirius with Jim Norton and he
brought in this the guy who basically
created mine hunter he was this like
he's interviewed all the serial killers
and speaks to him and they brought him
in I think his name's John Douglas they
brought him in he's just talking it was
fascinating let's go [ __ ] so I got his
book almost finished his book I'm like
this is great man and then started
listening to podcasts he's on it's just
about like murder and death and I
started looking up all this Charles
Manson stuff that I've been having awful
nightmares and been a little depressed
and you know me I'm it's very rare I'm
down it's just a dark [ __ ] world man
yeah you'd watch those true crime shows
oh [ __ ] your head aha
dude it makes you scared everything but
it's also going on it's going on in very
small numbers very very small numbers
but it is going on what it is is people
that have been abused people have been
[ __ ] up Psychopaths and people that
have been through the correction system
through the penal system yeah that's a
lot of it's so dark man there's not that
many of them and this this guy has three
daughters that's like how can you keep
down about this seven-year old terrible
story and I see how can you go home man
and sleep he's like eventually you know
it's just a job like it does affect me a
little bit I'm like do you just lock up
your kids like I'd be like just from
hearing you I I don't my son go to
school I don't leaving you think now you
learn to manage it and he did say that
he's like that this is the exception
like there's some dark stuff out there
but these gentlemen die and he interview
Charles Manson you've seen how he's five
too and he always has to speak over you
no matter what's going on so they're in
this room there's three people and
Charles Manson he got on a chair and
stood over him shouted down to him what
is he saying
I know pressure I convert him into me
man he people made me eat your garbage
man man man I'm product of your society
man he's [ __ ] crazy he was crazy he
has a quote I was reading again I'm too
into it man I'm quoting Charles Manson
what's going on in my life he was saying
that uh it used to be like you were the
exception when you're crazy now
everybody's crazy doesn't man smoke yeah
hmm he's like used to be kind of cool
then thing to be crazy
you know inside everybody's crazy well
he made it popular the [ __ ] do you know
how popular that [ __ ] crazy serial
killer is and all his followers oh my
god even to this day like I was reading
this article in Rolling Stones how many
books and even merch and to Dubai locks
of his hair is 50 grams going for 50
grand by locks of his hair and how he
sells merch that's 15 grams locks of his
hair yeah how much is a lock like what
does that mean what does that get you I
don't know well you could last out on
the bed cut a lock in half I'm saying to
say how much oh let's split it put it in
here say how many hairs pista what if he
shaves his balls and you give like a
saran wrap baggie of his pubes how much
is not 100 G's piece of his probably
dick piece under jeez dude Charles
Manson dick piece he was married when he
died the crazy [ __ ] fine serial
killers in jail and marry them happen
with Richard Ramirez The Night Stalker
there's just a factual thing to a night
yeah the some women want to be around
killers and even in particular guys have
killed women how crazy is that it's very
crazy can you imagine when your
daughter's when they're let's say 22
Mary's a serial core in prison at least
you know she's not gonna die but safe
look there's people out there I'll have
to tell you I do a [ __ ] terrible job
of raising their kids you know it's one
of the reasons why people like you
people like many people that get into
being a parent that really enjoy it when
you see something like that it's even
more disturbing because you know that
when you see a serial killer or
someone's [ __ ] up that person was a
baby that had a terrible life or almost
always they just got a shitty roll the
dice they got bad parents usually the
moms it's a relationship with the moms
that [ __ ] them up not so much the
father's usually them it's a mother-son
relationship really yeah you usually
always mother-son and that's what
usually causes the whole white Norman
Bates from psycho soil so dead on right
yep he's dealing with his mom please mom
that guy and he's the one who literally
he's Jeffrey Dahmer
Charles Manson it when there's something
got like he was talking about Jon Benet
which you know I'm from Denver when
school in Boulder that was the Jon Benet
Ramsey murder case was such a big deal
yeah
and still cancel that out they can't
they can't sell it no I had a buddy my
strength coach got crease rented it was
like a [ __ ] ghost and moved in there
like right after the murders anyway so I
handle it freak out
now he's cool he's from Louisiana like
real tough dude didn't give a [ __ ] there
must in a chromosome down there yeah
you'd be pretty crazy to move in there
even it was a great deal and it's a
great spot it was for sale four years
four years I think you might have
knocked it down they should I drove to
the OJ Simpson should knock it down they
should take out all the dirt and replace
it with new dirt yeah the shysters doing
everything just knock it down and dig a
hole all the way to hell whenever the
[ __ ] dirt was there so dirty man but
that dude he was just talking talking
and it was fascinating I didn't say a
word and then went to JonBenet I'm like
who I'm gonna chime in here cuz I know
this case and I know it well and she
asked him a question there was like my
time to jump in I go yeah but yeah I was
probably the parents right or maybe the
son and he has to acknowledge me this
entire interview I don't know if Jimmy
remember noted this and he goes what did
you say I was and I could tell I [ __ ]
up I guess it's probably the parents are
the son right he is absolutely not
absolutely not Brendan and then goes on
how ridiculously of an assumption that
is and I go well who does he think did
it uh he was it's not them he any any
ghost he was the promise is the the
narrative that got painted outside of
that when everything the media was going
crazy and even the pup the boulder
police he goes they were so far off and
he listed like ten reasons why it wasn't
them and I kind of felt like an idiot I
went very cool I'll buy the book on
there shut the [ __ ] up now the only
problem was that a handwriting expert
had connected the mother's handwriting
to the ransom note Duke get him on this
podcast be [ __ ] fascinating doing
promotion right now yeah I have no idea
who killed John Johnny Douglas this
guy's you remember I don't think he
knows no no he knows it he can tell you
from his seventy years of experience
dealing with murders it's not the
parents but he had like evidence why it
was it I said the same things right I'm
balls deep in where Jon Benet I grew up
around it it was like such a culture
phenomena did he say who he thinks about
yeah he
I forget but it's not the pick someone
who's alive I don't know you gotta have
a marker it was so fast I'm telling you
I've listened a shitload of Scioscia's
and I was so into this man I didn't
promote my special as their pro my
special I don't say a word
yeah I made one stupid comm about
JonBenet's family and then he was like
shut the [ __ ] up those [ __ ] shows are
very compelling then why I'm sure what
do you think why are we well like why am
i drawn to em I [ __ ] up why am i drawn
to this you are [ __ ] up you're just
like everybody else because I Charles
Manson's pubes on ebay how much you pay
70 G's 70 G's pubes they plucked them
out so it has some DNA and I'm dude you
could recreate Charles Manson what is it
Charles Manson's hair $2,400 doctor bag
of hair off the head of Charles Manson
was obtained July 2016 from an associate
of Charles Manson oh no that's leo a
will be a certificate of authenticity
will be included upon purchase by the
way do you know there are no
certificates of authenticity when it
comes to Charles Manson's hair it's not
like there's an accrediting body whose I
can light we go over every aspect
purchase that's its weak demand you want
that 1970s hair straight you don't want
the too updated you want to be there
when he cuts it off really yeah you want
to film him cutting it off and then you
want to vacuum seal it and sign it and
film the whole thing you put it in one
of them [ __ ] vacuum bags and sell and
then seal it yeah that way no one's
touched it chops right off his hair you
got video footage of it you got video
footage of him author I or autographing
the bag the [ __ ] is wrong with us why
are we talking about this
[Applause]